2014 was quite the year for the Nintendo
Wii U and it seems like 2015's got some
great games coming up for that system as
well one of which will hopefully be the
new Zelda Peter I see you rubbing your
loins was I in my mind wishful thinking
you're that you're doing that I'd get a
good better Wow no all right Peter
you're excited though yeah a new zelda
yeah what's not to be excited dude yeah
open world Zelda yes I mean I didn't
honestly like the last Zelda game I play
that I enjoyed was on the 3ds right the
love spiritually between worlds all
rights all right now gamespot's game of
the year for 2013 indeed spirit truck
but like I played Skyward Sword and I I
got I felt burned right away really it
was like two hours of them treating link
like he is the most boneheaded subhuman
to ever walk the plan okay yes but I
will stand up for that game only because
once you get past that it's a pretty
great game sure a lot of people enjoyed
it sure I couldn't get past it it's like
hey hey Peter no I remember this huge
bird that you've been like life partners
with your entire existence how could you
forget about it here so sleepy like oh
well the new zelda m is going to s be
more of an open-world affair which is
kind of like Zelda has always had like
an open world like a large world to
explore and maybe in a more traditional
kind of you know old nes / talk about
the first game definitely yeah yeah yeah
and yeah like the hub world and then the
dungeons are like little folks off of it
you know obviously the term open world
now sort of means something else in like
the the modern video game language sure
and so what type of stuff would you like
guys like to see Peter first of all that
like have taken from other open world
games as we see today like brought into
the cell the universe mmm I'm just gonna
avoid the whole thing from other games
thing yeah yeah yeah so I mean Zelda was
sort of created out of Shigeru
Miyamoto's love of nature right yeah and
that game is always kind of toyed with
you know the you know the outdoors right
open world game you know with the wii u
they're able to make this huge expansive
world things that you know in the real
world if you were to sort of deal with
an environment
large you would have to do things like
camp at night hmm you would probably
have to forage for materials to make
stuff I mean that's the kind of things
that I would love to see injected into
Zelda I don't know that the main formula
has to change mmm I mean you could even
adopt the same system from a link
between worlds where you rent equipment
you know say you know but yeah I would
love to see see link really sort of tied
in with nature and maybe even something
like a real-time day/night cycle to
encourage players to all encourage devs
to do something interesting with that
you know with multiple instances of the
same world but with a different things
happening and you know yeah like have
linked maybe have to set up camp mmm the
Zelda series has always had like a sort
of an interesting relationship with the
day/night cycle some games some games
have it some games didn't have it in
like towns for instance some did in the
overworld but then you look at something
like majora's mask which was a game that
was almost defined by the fact that like
nighttime was a was a constant threat
and what type of stuff would you like to
see Zelda universe do with like a
regular day night cycle like stuff like
we see in other games where you know
maybe it's easier to attack it like a
camp at a different time or may very
well Final Fantasy 15 is doing something
where the enemies at night are stronger
and different you know and like to see
something like that where they can you
know things that are sort of you know
recoil in the daylight might be no come
out of their little caves and actually
pose a bigger threat to link but then
maybe the rewards could be better as
well but yeah like I think if you could
do that and have links sort of deal with
you know like when you turn off the game
like have link set up camp right or if
it's during the daytime have him go do
some tasks you know while the sun's
still out I don't know I just I would
just love to see some of that and maybe
if they could bring back someone like
you know boating or flying all right
yeah yeah I'll give link you know he
always has a relationship with Epona and
Skyward Sword he had the bird I mean I
don't see why you couldn't bring another
bird into the equation and why link also
couldn't hop on another boat like he
didn't win winner at crissy you were
talking before about the sort of the
relationship with opponent had like
other games have used horse riding and
like transportation to good effect
probably red dead redemption yeah I mean
I was thinking about okay so what is
it's kind of an open world what what
makes me want to stay in an open world
what's an open world that I've liked is
relished being in the openness of it not
just kind of passing through and red
dead redemption as a stellar example I
think one of the reasons is harks back
to what Peter is saying is about that
connection with nature having having
moments where I'm just like riding along
a hillside and like I just want to stop
and take in the view because oh my god
this is beautiful or you know like I see
some birds off in the distance or
something and just like just like have a
moment that makes me feel connected
makes me feel like exploration is a
reward in and of itself just because of
the design I do think that there are
ways to use a horse that's that could be
more creative and could sort of create
those kind of emerging opportunities you
know not know Allah Far Cry we're like
some you run by and some people were
just in a fight and maybe you come help
them out or you know in red dead you
have those two or you like a woman's out
in the desert you go help her and like
maybe you actually help her or maybe
like three dudes pop out from her busted
cart and try to shoot you like I think
emergent stuff like that could be neat
for the Zelda universe because they've
always felt you know compared to like a
red dead I feel like Zelda places have
always felt like towns are where people
are right and like maybe there's that
one guy by that tree but they open world
doesn't quite feel as lived in by the
residents of the world and a lot of
times it's like oh because there are
monsters out there that's the way they
explain it but I think that like having
it be more lived in and having a little
more character like from the people you
encounter um world could be really neat
one of the things that on my limited my
experience result is relatively limited
I think especially in comparison to you
Peter one of the things i always felt
yeah right yeah you hell eliminate don't
wanna know but one of the things that I
always find interesting about the Zelda
games is that they are very focused on
the protagonist and the sort of thing
that we see a lot of an open world games
now is that often the world itself is
the actual character and you're just
kind of playing a part in it I guess by
definition of like his sort of I guess
quest that it's always going to be about
him but I always feel like they feel you
know
not to detriment necessarily but they
feel like worlds that have been put out
there so that Zelda or sorry so that
link can interact with them I never get
a real sense of place from a lot of
these games and what I'd like to see is
perhaps why you see in games like Skyrim
or fall out where you kind of you run
into almost inconsequential like color
stories like side quests that may end up
benefiting you in terms of like
equipment you have or like your your
character or they might just be there as
like options that give you sort of a
better understanding of the world
because the worlds in Zelda are always
so lost and interesting and beautiful
but I never feel like connected them
didn't just from your experience in
playing other Zelda games do you think
that that that's a fair assessment that
like those games are kind of that they
don't have that much depth to them as
like societies or places that people
live in yeah I can't really think of a
game that's really dealt like taking a
deep dive into the culture of the world
of Hyrule maybe that's because it's it's
already established in a way and we know
but it but it does change it does change
I think like a good example from the
trailer that they showed during e3 I was
linked just sort of hanging out on the
hill and you see that sort of monster in
the background and then he kind of rides
up to it and they fight it's not exactly
what you're talking about but I think
it's that at least shows me that it's a
living breathing world that's out there
and when link is sort of interacting
with this you know this monster it's
sort of it's not like a guy who's sort
of like placed between him and objective
yeah you know given the open-world
aspect of it you're going to expect
these sort of emergent experiences but
but hopefully that's indicative of maybe
you know a Hyrule that's in I mean I'd
love to see a Hyrule before it's all
established you know like as these
villages are being set up you know as
people are learning to live off the land
maybe or a nun then build their society
around that like that'd be really cool
yeah yeah like a frontier kind of part
of our oil like you've got the core a
probably have a castle right but like
the areas where people are like just
sort of setting out and like big Scott
wouldn't bunch wooden sticks around
their tents yeah I mean I dude I'd like
it without a castle honestly like it'd
be great to see something that is really
kind of primitive finis
excellent I be interesting yeah I think
that for me like one of one of the other
things that I think that places of the
Delta could stand to grow is with NPCs
and as you know because you have the one
so you just there like kind of silly
they're just sitting around you come up
to them and they make a little joke and
then you have the ones that you are a
little more substantial you like maybe
do one quest for them you gather the
ladies chickens or and then you have the
ones that are recurring quests where
you've got a weird octopus lady under a
mountain that you keep bringing her
baby's back to I feel like I feel like
you know I want to have some more
articulation in terms of the level of
NPCs so like give me someone who I
talked to and like have a relationship
with and it deepens and when I come back
they say it's great to see you again
when I come back the third time they say
hey man how's it been going look I've
been really how like having a tough time
and you get some more dialogue out of
them you get some more personality
because link is not exactly overflowing
with personality yeah you know he's kind
of a cipher for you the player so in
order for there to be personality in the
game the world needs to have it and the
people need to have it and then if you
talk to those people enough then
eventually you get to have sex with them
like in mass effect yeah what can help
that's the future of all video games
eventually it's a weird segue into my
mention of the gravedigger from Ocarina
of Time not somebody to want to have sex
with their sadly but was a good example
of an NPC in a Zelda world that is that
has some depth you know you get to learn
a little bit about him and actually feel
something for him Dante excellent i
guess we'll find out later this year
join me Peter join me Chris do it join
me and I hope you're all loving your
loins at home as well and the new zelda
game will be out on with you later this
year if you have any thoughts on what
you think should be in the game by all
means put them in the comments below or
send us what you think on the twitters